gotcha you click thank you
by the way but why did you click on this
and not like that or that or that
clickbait maybe but click bates not art
it's science here's how it works
trick number one emotional manipulation
if it gives you feels you seek it out
inspiration nostalgia heartbreak joy
these are things that make you click
you'll never believe how this will make
you feel and that brings us to finding
number two curiosity it killed the cat
but not the kittens one of those kittens
gonna do on that slide what's going on
here is what social scientists called
the information gap headline promises to
teach you something you didn't even know
you didn't know makes that promise you
want to fulfill so trick number three
anticipation you know that feeling you
get when you're gonna watch those
kittens that's your limbic system giving
you a little squirt of neurotransmitter
like dopamine telling you that you're
feeling something good now here's the
cool thing that actually happens before
you see the kidney so headline that
promises like BFFs with kittens gonna do
something fun that gives you the hit
even before you read the story that is
in other words click that but what if it
doesn't pay off
what if the animals aren't cute enough
well that brings us to trick number four
it's called the gamblers paradox
so do you one once you already got the
limbic hit of liking some headline even
if the next one that's listicle that you
have such high hopes for doesn't quite
work out your brain thinks maybe the
next click might or the one after that
or the one after that so you just keep
pulling the lever you'll never believe
the eight crazy things that you'll do
they click the next
it not that you know we acquired
whatever do anything quite so pendants
rules hidden snipers